hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to SCP containment
which as you can tell by the thumping
music in my ears that there is a billy
chasing me no not a billion old man
Larry Craddock Larry I don't even
remember what their names are either way
he's a dick and we're Oh Oh God okay
there I am okay so either way we're
probably gonna die which is a problem
dammit I forgot boobie get your game on
go [ __ ] yourself
alright saamana Oh poopy I remember now
I remember it forcing me to go
downstairs which means that I have no
choice
Adi the face Oh God oh he's so he's so
bad what the [ __ ] with that right now
I'm an all-star get my game on hey hey
Raynor where the hell am I going I don't
remember any of this it's totally
foreign to me at the moment okay so this
is a new sewer area that I have not been
before it's filled with mazes
[Music]
don't even do it Larry Larry Larry she's
gonna open I'm dead honor no oh he's
gonna kill me he's gonna send me into
his pocket world oh no what the [ __ ]
[Music]
oh god that Rumble does not sound good
I've heard some good rumbles before and
that doesn't sound like one of them that
I know so I got a radical area on my
butt don't know how it got away from
them that one time the door was just
waiting for him to pop open at me what a
dick bag
what a dick big so what you're saying is
some of these ain't real or did I
actually fall okay that's the one I came
out of so the low ominous Rumble um
that's good
I don't know what to make of this
I really don't cuz I've never seen this
before so I have no idea what I'm
supposed to do we're not supposed to do
this episode got off to a rather
energetic start and I'm not prepared for
this it's off usually these SCP episode
bag parson well I would I would say that
my name isn't coursing like I've said
before but at this point I don't even
mind any sort of human contact would be
nice what's your that damn computer my
phone's ringing you should be on silent
do not disturb I'm busy right now
I'm Way too up in this very professional
recording situation actually I would
like to comment now professional is I'm
recording on a shoe if anyone wants to
know how professional my setup is
on a shoe okay so ah Brno yes actually
oh good I want to [ __ ] you thank you
poop poopy poop radical Aryan could do
that okay so I can't get through there
so I'm an area that I've kind of been
before but I've had not really not
really what could go wrong
god damn it exactly this had enough
clearance somehow so light containment
zone wait does this just mean that I've
been here before
bag of dicks oh god damn it I just
cycled back to work already was the
point even going down in the sewers the
answer is there was no point I was
supposed to go on the other sewers so
arguably I have to go back oddly enough
that would be what I would guess that I
would have to do what you doing there
little boy Little Billy boo okay you you
have fun screwing yourself I'm gonna go
out this episode does not become this
procedure has not been good as much
rather happen heard
I hear I heard Skippy steps boom again I
know these things I've been playing this
game for a long time I know when things
are digging with me and I heard some
ticket tree going on god this this is
unpleasant
I really hope there aren't like monsters
that I can't see in the darkness and
everyone in the comments like ranting
and raving and how I didn't see them cuz
that would be just delightful alright so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go back
to where I started
what kenan birkan i'm up did a crash the
crash didn't it god damn it
it crashed okay we're okay as long as it
just crashed nothing happened to me okay
I'm back now I don't know exactly what
happened but my whole second harddrive
shirt actually up my computer has not
been going well I've had quite a few
failed recordings what so I I'm just a
little paranoid for multiple reasons one
in game two about my recording self
failing but I check this one it's all
good oddly if you guys can see it it's
obviously good wait a minute where it
was I did I go back to where I was or do
don't go back to where I came from I
don't remember I don't remember no no
this is the first way because we're to
go oh is this here we go okay so this is
the first way because it wasn't on this
outer wall lives on the inner wall so I
need to go back this way to go to the
other one to be able to go down into the
sewers again to be able to go through
the area
I got spun around again to where I need
to go such that no it's filled with lies
and poop booth lies because after the
crash I can't remember where the same
actually dropped me off
homina I'm just gonna go down here to
the other side and see if that's where
the goddamn eggs it is
I don't know what I'm doing really up
there isn't a Billy or some down here
that would be the worst would be Arab
okay so it should just be no over the
other way I don't know the layout of it
I don't know if it's just a big square
grid
here's it it might be it's something
that this is not a square you suck god
screw you okay what was that
okay here we go found it oh come on
there's nothing here it's open okay what
if I push it like this
oh thank you gotta be tender and mild
though you gotta be gentle got sweet
talking hello bug stop spinning her
around my hand was not even on my mouse
that time I know you're doing it game
son of a [ __ ] okay so it was a Larry
here before that was kind of rushing me
through so I'm assuming that if I go
this way
wait no this fits all wrong I remember
which way I went and let me check my I
already been that way what does that
mean for me now what does that mean for
me
who's out there
you got some angry fellers oh this is
well lit the music has changed again I
don't remember it going through quite as
many palette shapes this was worth
before this I've already been down here
this is where the zombo's was tonight
sprint through this way tonight I did
tonight I've encountered the zombies
like ten different times have gone this
way damn it damn it damn it damn it damn
it
dagnabbit damn it damn it okay so I
gotta go back up of a [ __ ] okay so I
gotta go back up and I gotta let me go
back you gotta make me go through those
Abhi's aren't you well screw you too
oh why isn't this open I swear this
can't be like another zombie area there
can't be like unlimited number of plague
doctors because that's what the [ __ ]
right for you and your zombie age'
switch this switch this I'm gonna fall
over and die if I save now I'm dead eat
me up
come on me come on
greetings yes how are you hello whoa
Jesus
stop being so creepy I touch me so I
guess I'm nothing to say about that
apparently so it's gonna sever my thing
took you enough I was giving you a hug
right on your face okay let's try this
again
god damn memory access violation Wow so
anyway all right I've had enough crashes
with this game I apologize if this
episode is a little bit shorter by
hopefully you guys don't mind because
holy hell this episode has been not fair
to me I'll play this again soon
sooner than the soon I said in the last
episode of soon so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotations or
down in the description below for my
full SCP canaima Beach playlist there's
like 45 episodes tons of stuff to watch
go back in time see it all thanks again
everybody and as always I will see you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay